well thank you all for being here thank
you for inviting me to this
distinguished seminar my wife and I are
both busy professionals so we have a
shared uh you know Google Calendar where
we're trapped into income trap
um so we have to do these things and so
I usually apprise her of where I'm going
and I wrote down for this event I wrote
you know speak at Hillsdale it was only
when the event was drawing close that I
mentioned that oh yeah it's actually in
Palm Springs and she said
I was like no you know they have this
they have this conference and it's okay
I mean she doesn't mind coming am I
coming this way and that but it just
puts my work when I'm out doing speaking
gigs in a different light because you
know it's one thing to go to Hillsdale
Michigan in the dead of winter and
another to be here so
um
anyway you didn't come here to hear my
wife jokes so let me let me proceed
um
I was asked to address the conservative
divide over drag queen's Story Hour and
I will address that of that divide
but I'll also push us Beyond it
because let's be honest do we really
want to spend an hour on a glorious
Golden State morning like this one
talking about men in latex boots
twerking in front of toddlers
no we do not
hillsdale's choice of topic though no
doubt had to do with the dust up I
created a few years ago after publishing
an essay in first things magazine
headlined against David frenchism
we are in fact fast approaching the
fourth anniversary of that essay
the essay that launched a thousand
op-eds and served as quote a full
employment bill for the conservative
commentariat as Ross daufat put it at
the time
coining and criticizing frenchism is
still one of the things with which I'm
credited even by readers otherwise
unfamiliar with my work I'll travel to
the Balkans and people ask me now what
is frenchism
well the the basic of the
Contour of the argument was that a drag
queen story is happening B it represents
a profound cultural crisis and C it
represents a failure of the conventional
social conservative movement as embodied
by David French but not only David
French
four years ago if I would wish for my
byline to be tightly associated with
either Mr French or with drag queens I
would have instantly replied no hell no
nor did I expect a single sentence from
that essay my Battle Cry that quote we
must fight the culture war with the aim
of defeating the enemy and enjoying the
spoils in the former in the form of a
Public Square reordered to the common
good and ultimately the highest good to
find its way into hundreds of columns
and books
with its admittedly unstable mix of
Thomas piety and Iranian militancy that
sentence is likely to be etched into my
gravestone
it's almost surreal to reflect on those
heated debates and the events that have
transpired since then
back then much of the institutional
rights circled the wagons around Mr
French while subjecting me to a kind of
ostracism
mainstream figures who initially sided
with the Persian in the franco-persian
take wars were few and far between
most of the editors of first things my
friends Roger Kimball of the new
Criterion and Chris Buskirk and Julie
Kelly of American greatness some
comrades at the Federalists and oddly
enough the Evangelical intellectual Alan
Jacobs
who gave me most of the points on
substance in an essay for the Atlantic
even as he deplored my polemical style
in a rather throat-clearing manner
far more typical was my own former boss
and Mentor at the Wall Street Journal
editorial Pages Brett Stevens who penned
and denunciation of me in the times
under the delicious headline the high
Church of the low blow
National Review where French was
employed at the time naturally led the
way with a dozen apologies for their man
and attempted takedowns of yours truly
how things have changed
today preventing interactions between
kids and drag queens treated as surab
amari's dangerous Theocratic brainstorm
in 2019 is the stuff of suburban Wineman
Politics the mainstream posture on the
right and the official policy of Florida
Governor Ron desantis's Administration
even National Review is wising up in a
brief blog post published last summer
and ours Charlie cook asked in apparent
exasperation how
how did we reach the point at which drag
queens in schools became a topic that is
routinely debated in domestic American
politics how did drag queens get into
schools in the first place end quote
the media cause of Mr Cook's vexation
was Michigan attorney general Dana
nessel's call for quote a drag queen in
every school end quote
Nestle later claimed that she was
speaking in jest but she's far from the
only Democratic official to speak out
recently in favor of having drag queens
perform before children in public
schools
California state Senator Scott weiner
likewise mused about quote offering drag
queen 101 as part of the K-12 curriculum
adding quote
attending drag queen Story Hour would
satisfy this requirement end quote
responding to criticism of drag events
for children in New York City schools
for which the Department of Education
has a two hundred thousand dollar budget
a doe spokesman countered quote this is
life-saving and affirming work we
believe our schools play a critical role
in helping young people learn about res
about about and respect people who may
be different from them end quote and on
and on
thus what began as a seemingly marginal
voluntary private program held in a few
public libraries has now embedded itself
in some Urban school districts and may
well expand its hold still further
of course my 2019 contained at its heart
a warning about precisely this dynamic
my main argument had to do with the
nature of liberal claims about autonomy
gender ideologues I contended take the
logic of maximal autonomy cherished by
dogmatic classical liberals and
Libertarians like French to its logical
terminus
to fully substantiate Atomic autonomy
claims about gender and sexuality it
isn't enough to secure the private right
to do X rather Society must positively
approve of x
as I wrote at the time and forgive me
for the long self quotation
individual experiments in living say
taking your kid to a drag reading hour
at a public library cannot be sustained
without some level of moral approval
without the community
autonomy maximizing liberalism is
normative in its own Twisted way thus it
represents the interiorization and
fulfillment of French's world view the
more conservative liberals that's a term
you should grapple with conservative
liberals like French insist on autonomy
the more they strengthen the bully's
position this far with autonomy they
insist and not any farther
but why should the other side stop why
shouldn't this new aggressive vision of
maximal autonomy overtake the old
now this line of thinking more or less
answers Mr Cook's questions posed three
or four years after the frenchism
brouhaha how did we get here
mine is an argument about the historical
operation of liberal ideology
liberalism always Begins by asserting a
private right to deviate from the
communal Norm but it never stops there
gradually the private deviation comes to
swallow the public so that the deviation
becomes the norm and the norm deviant
in 2019 when I published against David
frenchism we were at the private right
stage of liberal ideology with respect
to drag queens reading for kids at that
stage NR doubled down on libertarian
bromides about Viewpoint neutrality and
Free Speech while poo pooing concerns
about the rise of dksh dqsh
in his initial response to my broadside
Mr French championed liberal neutrality
as the guardian of both Christian groups
and drag queens later he went further
telling the New Yorker magazine in a
joint profile of the two of us that
quote the fact that a person can get a
room in a library and hold drag queen
Story Hour hour that's one of the
blessings of liberty end quote
his colleagues Rich Lowry Jonah Goldberg
Kevin Williamson and many others rushed
to his defense
autonomy maximizing liberalism remained
unquestionable even as events continue
to reveal its culturally acidic
tendencies
the United States declared a writer
named J.J McCullough in NR quote is
organized as a religiously neutral
public and no account of the good life
can be enshrined in its institutions
this even as race and gender ideologues
were doing just that if he and his
colleagues would but look around them
Mr cook himself was no exception quotes
critics of the liberal order he wrote at
that time believe the system is unjust
because it merely pretends that
neutrality and Toleration while in fact
smuggling its own values and imposing
them on the Public Square end quote but
rest assured he went on the classically
liberal order places only one condition
on participant on participants and that
is that they agree not to try to abolish
or permanently take it over
well end quote that was 2019. here we
are in 2023 drag queen Story Hour
in its private rights stage has given
way to the normative eyes and enforced
stage prompting cook to rage why
why indeed one almost feels sorry for
him
okay so much for gloating and I told you
so's
now much as it might surprise some to
hear this I take scant pleasure in the
fact that the institutional right now
seems seems to have turned decisively in
my direction and against frenchism
today's conservative movement is hyper
energized on the culture War Front you
would think this should leave me content
but I am not
because I'm afraid the new posture isn't
up to the task the right has said for
itself of beating back the whole complex
of wokism of which drag queen's Story
Hour is but one expression
although it can appear more muscular or
more based as your kids might say
than French's approach it remains
fundamentally wedded to the same kind of
culturalism that characterizes that
characterizes frenchism
now what do I mean by culturalism
culturalism is a tendency to Silo
cultural phenomena from the material
conditions that serve as the substrate
of culture condition conditions that
structure ordinary people's cultural
perceptions and their experiences
culturalism is in part a product of a
deeply embedded conservative tendency
toward excessive idealism
if old school leftists of a certain sort
erred by reducing reducing all cultural
phenomena to a given Society is quote
mode and relations of production many on
the right mistakenly go to the opposite
extreme denying any Nexus between the
prevailing ideas and the class Dynamics
and hierarchies of society in this Frame
culture becomes a sort of autonomous
realm that is completely innocent of the
way we organize our larger politics and
political economy
and wokeness and gender ideology become
just another set of bad ideas a mind
virus that has out of the blue infected
our institutions they can therefore be
ousted if we just State the right ideas
emphatically enough in this telling
anytime you hear someone lament the
state of the culture
when he does that you have to ask what
kind of analysis or diagnosis diagnosis
is foreclosed by talking about the
culture in this way
if some social crisis is framed as a
purely cultural problem then all that's
needful that is needful is a cultural
fix evangelize the culture if I could
just write one more op-ed or white paper
people can tell that true Liberty means
getting married forming a family serving
neighbor a neighborhood and I can change
the nation
of course nothing changes that way we
desperately need a deeper analysis of
the woke gender ideology complex one
that's attentive to material reality
now my own first encounter with the
complex of ideas and practices now known
as woke
came when a much younger version of
myself was about to embark on his first
job out of college
the year was 2005. the scene a giant
Auditorium in Houston Texas where
hundreds of recent college graduates had
gathered for a lesson in diversity
community and Leadership
at 20 years old I was the youngest of
the bunch
we were members of an organization
called Teach for America which recruits
promising recent graduates to spend two
years teaching in Public School
classrooms set in some of the nation's
poorest regions but not before immersing
us in a bath of race sex and gender
Theory
all the elements we now associate with
wokism were present there in embryonic
form in that Houston Auditorium
the cultivation of ever more exotic and
boutique grievances the competition for
victim status the reduction of complex
social problems to an obsession with
using the right kind of language the
denial of agency to victim groups the
cholera sorry corollary duty of dominant
groups to pursue social change mainly by
pursuing individual self-improvement
for America would have a sit in circles
and present our quote narratives
participants like from subaltern
backgrounds were expected to tell
stories of repression and exclusion
while those who came from the dominant
culture had to unpack their Privileges
and biases in front of the group
now at the time I had only immigrated to
the United States from Iran six years
earlier and needless to say sitting
around in circles to unpack your biases
was not something people did in the
Islamic Republic